- I'm Wes Chatham
and here are five shows to check out
if you loved The Expanse, on Binge Guide.
- Thanks Wes I couldn't
have said it better myself
and we are big fans of The
Expanse on Amazon Prime.
With three Certified Fresh seasons
filled with galactic
action, existential drama,
and world exploring adventure,
it's not hard to see why.
So if you're a fan
looking for more to love
after The Expanse,
we think that these space-veering shows
will launch your next few binge sessions
into a new dimension,
starting with our family
friendly pick, "Lost in Space."
This Netflix reboot of the
TV series of the same name
follows adventures of the Robinson family
as they navigate the cosmos
after getting lost in space.
I mean the title says it all.
What can I say?
Look beyond the title though,
and you'll find a modern
take on the classic series
with something for everyone
in your own family,
with tons of safe for kids action.
That's coupled with a large heart
and ambitious production values
that should attract sci-fi adventure fans.
And with a third and
final season on the way
you can quickly get caught
up with the first two seasons
in just about 20 hours
which sounds blissful
compared to being, you
know, lost in space.
Okay, I'm done sorry.
Next up is our throwback pick
and that is going to
"Battlestar Galactica."
This re-imagining of the '70s TV show
follows humanity's war
with the android race
known as the Cylons and bucks
the trend of the original spin
on "Star Wars" in favor of a darker tone
in seriously heady twists
that strongly resonated
with modern audiences.
With two certified first seasons
and a massive cult following,
the four season series has been praised
for its addictive high-minded
themes and complex storylines.
And it's frequently been called
one of the greatest
sci-fi series of all time.
With 76 episodes total
you can binge a series
in about 56 hours,
which is nothing compared
to the amount of time
you'll spend contemplating
all the storylines.
Another entry into a classic universe
is our certified fresh
pick "Star Trek Discovery."
This CBS all access series
six plays roughly a decade
before "Star Trek" the original series
and explores the earlier days
of the United Federation
of Planets and the advent
of war with the Klingons.*
Critics praise "Discovery's"
ability to forge its own path
while effectively dramatizing
new takes on the Lord
that results in a solid
franchise installment
for the next generation of Trek fans.
With three seasons, you can
watch "Star Trek Discovery"
in about 26 hours after
which you'll have boldly
gone where no couch has gone before.
Next up is our audience pick
going to the alternative history
series "For All Mankind."
This Apple TV plus drama
from "Battlestar Galactica"
creator Ronald D. Moore,
blends true life characters
with fictional events
like the Russian's landing
on the moon first.
To ask the question
what would have happened
if the space race never ended.
With stellar production values,
incredible cast and some
very timely storylines,
the show has the right
stuff to be unpredictable
and all inspiring.
You can watch the entire
first season in about 10 hours
and good news, season two is
a go for launch in early 2021
so be sure to keep a lookout.
And rounding out our
list is our editor's pick
"Raised By Wolves."
This Ridley Scott produced HBO Max series
revisits many of the sci-fi
masters hallmark themes
including androids, space
colonization and lots of action.
All while asking pretty big questions
about human nature and
what it means to be alive.
Critics say the show is filled
with Ridley Scott trademarks
like imagination and other worldly imagery
that will stimulate the mind and eye,
but also adds a surprising
amount of heart.
And with just 10 episodes you can binge
all of "Raised By Wolves"
in about 10 hours,
which I hear is how long
it feels to hibernate
for deep space exploration.
All right friends hopefully
this list will open your eyes
to a whole new galaxy
of content to explore.
Be sure to check out
the new "Rotten Tomatoes is Wrong" podcast
from Rotten Tomatoes because fresh rotten
is just the beginning of the conversation
and new episodes drop every Thursday.
And we'll see you back here
for more recommendations
based around and movies
and shows that you love
right here on the Rotten
Tomatoes "Binge Guide", bye.
(upbeat music)